welcome to this video playing f5 you see
playing f5 he is ok at least someone who
is sticking to his his guns national
Muslim Michael egner f porn I'm also f
porn but he's got the German German flag
there ok funny maybe I should have
played efore and maybe place the same
thing if i have the fret opening maybe
it's not very likely though okay so
maybe I should give me this retreat
square there and see me does he getting
me five maybe I want to play with c4
definitely the knight on c3 is not there
to to stay in the whole game keep dokie
g5 coming maybe ok I should get out of
the temple ma ice is going for that
hmm
not quite sure how to react to that if
he goes gee for not sure what this is
takes takes 95mm a bit strange this
position ok I just gain space and see
what is doing if he's not playing g4 not
sure if then that this made much sense
ok this thing h4 g4 however hmm still on
g4 I have 95 ok
hmm iodized is getting something really
quickly or ki tick or C playing this
Queen edge for
we niche for I have neither for I'm and
you cannot take on f 2 this is not going
to work takes takes Queen age 54 41
that's not that's not working let's do
this Queen f2 sorry night f2 it's not
working takes takes Queen age five okay
but here I can check on e4 I think and
then just row q 1 let's do that earlier
you could have taken with the Queen but
ok so i do i'm not sure i just want to
grab their own age 5 I think that the
chances form for an attack on his King a
bit to hire them to trade queens I have
to be cautious though if he moves the
King which it doesn't there was some ha
ok there were some ideas there but stunt
that he didn't move the king
takes takes takes you six Bishop takes
Queen g4 check you for roaches so I
cannot calculate that I'm just have to
trust my gut instinct down tsis Queen
bag can put the Queen back right open up
the sea pawn I didn't expect that move
at all okay so Queen Queen up for
possible Quincy five or look see one
hmm what is he doing there Queen f2s in
the is coming maybe yeah Queen 24 was a
stupid idea really completely
unnecessary check
ok maybe okay Bishop f4 I can actually
take it six how do i how do i turn the
windows though Queen to g3 maybe and
Queen g1 Queen g3 that might be the way
to go Queen Queen g5 I can go here also
for Quincy 7 that's a pretty big thread
yeah queen Quincy seven Quincy ate those
moose they should that should be good
time warning ok mmm hey six tough to
calculate this with no time then a six
was my idea Bishop takes Queen c7 pawn
takes an a6 yes Queen age for but I can
play can i play a seven Queen f 2 92 and
it's not totally clear
taking one b7 however is pretty clear
and I can play Queen edge for I can go
with the king check okay everyone let's
it's it's clear i even okay let's push
it's a bit hard to believe that this
should hold you six come on give me six
that will be 2500 even if even if I'm
not getting many points from the scale
back resign yeah four points for that
still still was kind of kind of tricky
yeah I round here I didn't it didn't
know what what what to make out that
looks dangerous okay I went here g4 damn
ok i'm a bit relief that the computer is
not saying that i'm losing or something
yeah here in fact he gives me a very big
edge yeah it was important to note that
this is really not possible I'm sorry
chick and Queen h5 that that should win
right yeah I saw that this is yes that
this is winning as he cannot go here Oh
actually 96 symbol that wins but I
didn't see that one I was thinking
Queenie age should be enough but it
isn't but 96 is the winner Queen h8 f8
mate cannot prevent that nice so this
and it takes yeah the computer just
takes h5 huh maybe I should have done
that I wasn't totally totally sure about
this look g6 yeah okay that also looks
nice for look at six
and maybe Queen g1 never came yeah I
can't didn't play it perfectly but this
is not a good idea and I went back to be
safe oh now he has a move rookie form
that is actually drawing or computer
give 000 not sure why 000 I look f8 now
very brutal for look f4 and then then
the draw check yeah yeah ok the engine
gave it as equal but yeah in fact be
five is good for white so I spotted that
that opportunity that was good a
seven-year Queen a five and wide wind
sound the ideas Quincy seven queen bee
eight this or queen c7 Quimby a that I
could have done that I was glad that has
spotted spotted this thing so the win is
a win so I'm close to my may all time
high them just a couple of just a couple
of points away thanks for watching